well here in the valley clark county and
the state are splitting one million
dollars in new funding it will expand
the unlv immigration clinic over the
next two years now they provide free
legal services to both children and
adults facing deportation hector mejia
has the story
with this new funding the unlv
immigration clinic now plans to open its
first permanent off-campus location
they're in the process of hiring staff
and choosing that location
handprints of actual clients line the
hallways of the unlv immigration clinic
these are children who were granted the
right to stay in the u.s the whole legal
process can take several years this is
critical for keeping families together
to make sure that people don't have an
empty chair at the dinner table for kids
who've seen or experienced awful things
to make sure they don't have to go back
to the people who attacked them most of
the clients here involve children
unaccompanied minors who fled horrendous
gang violence and social turmoil that's
according to director michael kagan the
clinic has about 150 active cases kagan
says while the 1 million dollars in new
funding from clark county and the state
is not going to meet every need it's a
huge step forward no matter what you
think about whether people should or
should not be deported i hope people can
agree that the process at least has to
be fair and this process cannot be fair
if people don't have legal advice we are
told someone is five times more likely
to avoid deportation if they have a
lawyer if you know someone who needs
legal advice you can call the clinic
directly their phone number is
702-895-2080 reporting from unlv hector
mejia live local now